y
[Música]
yo bailé en nombra a su consejero ron
klain como jefe de gabinete el
presidente del hecho de eeuu comenzó a
conformar la estructura de su gobierno y
ya se consideran nombres para los
demócratas mientras que donald trump
sigue sin aceptar la derrota de las
presidenciales
manifestaciones y cacerolazos contra el
nuevo presidente de perú manuel merino
miles de ciudadanos se sumaron a las
marchas en lima contra la destitución de
martín vizcarra y la toma de mando de
merino las protestas también continuaron
en otras ciudades del país como cusco y
arequipa
la pandemia de kobe 19 nueva tregua en
italia médicos y enfermeros de la nación
europea
alertaron que la situación de todos los
hospitales en el país está al borde del
colapso al haber superado ya el número
de pacientes ingresados por coronavirus
desde la primera ola tenemos reporte
desde roma
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco un gusto
saludarlos comenzamos este informativo
en eeuu donde el presidente electo joe
biden sigue adelante con su transición
el líder demócrata eligió a ron klein
para que sea su nuevo jefe de gabinete
ocupando una de las posiciones más
poderosas de la casa blanca esto debido
a que donald trump se ha negado a
reconocer la derrota a pesar del amplio
consenso que indica que la elección fue
libre y justa veamos el siguiente
informe
una primera cita importante para joe
biden el presidente electo anunció el
miércoles que ron klein un antiguo
asistente y asesor de campaña será su
jefe de gabinete en un comunicado bailén
escribió a klein como invaluable ya que
la administración entrante tiene un
difícil camino por delante su profunda y
variada experiencia y su capacidad para
trabajar con personas de todo espectro
político es precisamente lo que necesito
en un jefe de gabinete de la casa blanca
mientras enfrentamos este momento de
crisis y unimos a nuestro país
nuevamente klein es un político
experimentado estuvo a cargo de liderar
la respuesta de barack obama a la crisis
de salud del ébola en 2014 ahora se
espera que sea una figura clave la lucha
contra la pandemia del coronavirus desde
que fue declarado ganador el sábado va a
ir en ha estado ansioso por ponerse a
trabajar a medida que avanza con su
transición estableciendo un grupo de
trabajo sobre el coronavirus
investigando a los posibles miembros de
su gabinete y pronunciando discursos
sobre futuras políticas el miércoles
participó en una ceremonia del día de
los veteranos en filadelfia
asistió un evento fuera de washington su
primera aparición pública oficial desde
la votación del 3 de noviembre el
presidente ha desafiado continuamente
los resultados de las elecciones
presentando otra demanda en michigan y
haciendo afirmaciones falsas de fraude
generalizado en los últimos días
bailén ha enfatizado en que nada podría
detener la transición de poder se espera
que su posesión tenga lugar el 20 de
enero ante la negativa de donald trump
de reconocer estos resultados
electorales y debido a esto estancar el
proceso de transición de poder en el
país le preguntamos a nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cuáles
pueden ser los riesgos de una transición
lenta para la seguridad de eeuu y que
tuvo que ver la transición lenta en el
2000 con los atentados del 9/11 esto fue
lo que nos dijo
pues lo que preocupa mucho es raúl que
28 todavía pues no ha aceptado la la
derrota y ha congelado los fondos para
la transición esto obviamente también
tiene mucho efecto en la demora en los
procesos
el presidente electo joe biden tiene
4000 cargos públicos que tiene que
elegir 1200 de ellos tienen que pasar
por congreso por la aprobación del
congreso y 100 pues se están en más de
100 agencias estos cargos si se demorase
se sigue demorando esta transición pues
va a haber un problema y se va a demorar
en la aprobación de seguridad de estos
funcionarios además pues estos
funcionarios van a tener menos tiempo
para prepararse a sus cargos y ese es
importante lo que usted menciona sobre
la relación que tiene con los atentados
del 9/11 en la elecciones de alcorcón
trabulse donde bush llega a la
presidencia sólo tuvo bus 37 días para
hacer la transición según los reportes
de el comité del 9/11 de los atentados
del 9/11 este poco tiempo en la
transición tuvo un efecto directo
en la falta de preparación de los
funcionarios para estar mejor preparados
en casos de ataques terroristas y dijo
que esa relación directo tuvo efecto en
la facilitación que tuvieron los
terroristas para poder gestionar estos
atentados terroristas así que yo bailé
va a tener si sigue este proceso lento
muy pocos días para preparar a su
gabinete y esto podría poner en juego
podría poner en riesgo la seguridad de
eeuu cambiamos de información venimos
hasta américa latina' las protestas le
miden el pulso al nuevo presidente
interino de perú manuel merino las
manifestaciones no cesan desde que el
exmandatario martín vizcarra fue
destituido porque el congreso lo
consideró culpable de recibir sobornos
cuando era gobernador y lo declaró
incapaz moralmente de gobernar el país
andrea rincón nos cuenta más
el congreso peruano insiste en hablar
por el pueblo pero el pueblo dice otra
cosa así lo reclamaron en las calles
cientos de personas que salieron a
protestar por la destitución del
exmandatario martín vizcarra un día
después de que el poco conocido
presidente del congreso peruano manuel
merino asumiera su lugar
interinamente
bueno por la indignación que sentimos
todos al menos nosotros
como el congreso
podría ser tan expresamente una vacancia
por incapacidad moral el congreso
hablando de capacidad moral por favor
cuántas congresistas están investigados
ahora en medio de la carrera de merino
por juramentar a su gabinete para sacar
el país de una nueva fase de
inestabilidad política
el silencio inunda los partidos que
apoyaron la medida mientras las críticas
estallan entre los legisladores que la
rechazan la división más de las calles
al congreso y la desconexión se pone en
medio de la brecha entre el congreso y
la gente es anterior esta crisis y en
las dos crisis anteriores en general la
clase política ya que el congreso en
parte es que libre desconectada en la
gente no vemos en todos los estudios que
se han realizado y las encuestas de
opinión pública las protestas no cesan
desde la destitución de vizcarra por
presunta corrupción
merino el tercer presidente de perú en
cuatro años seguirá en el poder hasta
julio cuando asuma el nuevo mandatario
que escojan los peruanos en las
elecciones de abril
cambiamos de tema de la situación en
italia en cuanto a la pandemia de kobe
19 es alarmante las asociaciones de
médicos y enfermeros de la nación
europea alertaron que la situación de
todos los hospitales en el país está al
borde del colapso al haber superado ya
el número de pacientes ingresados por
coronavirus de la primera ola las
infecciones superaron este miércoles el
umbral del millón de casos y veintinueve
mil quinientas personas hospitalizadas
se supera un récord de ocupación
sanitaria para ampliar esta información
salud en este momento a nuestra
corresponsal en roma' natalia mendoza
natalia la saludo buen día como ya lo
comentábamos italia ya superó el
miércoles el umbral del millón de los
casos positivos de coronavirus
sobrepasando a mexico para convertirse
de uno de los diez países más afectados
a nivel mundial porque en pocos días
empeoró la situación sanitaria en ese
país
pues raúl es cierto en los últimos días
hemos asistido a un aumento exponencial
del contagio en el país en un mes el
número de pacientes hospitalizados en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos se
ha multiplicado por 7 ayer 623 decesos
fueron registrados en 24 horas este es
el peor dato de muertos en un día desde
el pasado 6 de abril aquí en italia
lohan y a inicios del mes de septiembre
el país se parecía a lograr resistir a
la segunda ola pero ahora la realidad es
que italia está en el ojo del ciclón la
situación está completamente fuera de
control no se logra hacerle seguimiento
a los casos positivos ni a los contactos
directos de estas personas en varias
regiones principalmente en lombardía
pero también en el sur del país regiones
que cuentan con infraestructuras
sanitarias más precarias mucho menos
desarrolladas que en el norte de italia
natalia esta situación está dando lugar
a escenas dramáticas en los hospitales
italianos que ocurre realmente
pues lo que ocurre es que el sistema de
salud pública italiana está al borde del
colapso y una prueba de esto son las
imágenes que llegan de un hospital en
nápoles en donde por falta de espacio
los enfermos de coronavirus no son
atendidos dentro del hospital sino en la
calle en el parqueadero se ve en las
filas de carros parqueados parados con
los enfermos de coronavirus acostados en
los puestos de atrás en las botellas de
oxígeno acomodadas en la calle en el
andén y los enfermeros que pasan de
carro en carro controlando la salud de
los pacientes la federación italiana de
médicos y anestesistas ha lanzado un
grito de alarma reclamando con fuerza un
nuevo confinamiento general una
hipótesis que por el momento el gobierno
italiano ha rechazado temiendo las las
consecuencias nefastas que esto pueda
tener en la economía del país dramáticas
imágenes y dramática la situación que
vive italia a natalia muchísimas gracias
por su reporte este jueves en medio de
la segunda ola el primer ministro
francés yann castex hablará para dar una
actualización de la pandemia de
coronavirus en el país ya que él
número de enfermos sigue aumentando lo
cual hace improbable cualquier
relajación del confinamiento a pesar del
descontento social matías arráez nos
trae la información
dos semanas después del segundo
confinamiento la situación en francia no
ha cambiado lo suficiente
todavía escuchamos a muchos doctores
directores de hospitales hablando de la
saturación de los hospitales no veo como
dos semanas de confinamiento han logrado
invertir la tendencia a hacer a todos
perderían credibilidad si después de dos
semanas dijeran ok bueno finalmente está
bien podemos relajarnos no tiene sentido
si el martes el ministro del interior
germán pidió a las autoridades locales
reforzar los controles no cambiará para
apretar el tornillo
creo que no cambiará nada la gente
necesita estar fuera de lo contrario
todos se volverán locos en algún momento
no puedes tener un discurso ir a
trabajar y quedarte en casa es difícil
si no tenemos menos riesgo de este
coronavirus por estar afuera que por
estar adentro por lo tanto en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos la
situación se vuelve más tensa día a día
como señal del colapso varios hospitales
han tenido que reprogramar operaciones
quirúrgicas en las regiones más
afectadas se están organizando traslados
de pacientes
seguimos con la actualización del
conflicto de nagorno karabaj a el
ministerio de defensa ruso publicó un
vídeo donde muestran vehículos militares
que transportan fuerzas para el
mantenimiento del acuerdo de paz en esa
región según el ejército se han
desplegado 8 helicópteros en la región
que se utilizarán para monitorear el
alto el alto al fuego así como para la
entrega de equipos y personal de otra
parte el ministerio informó del arribo
de 20 aviones tanques de guerra y más de
2.400 individuos en la zona que enfrentó
a armenia azerbaiyán por más de 44 días
el tifón banco golpea las provincias de
filipinas con vientos de más de 100
kilómetros por hora y se espera que
llegue a manila la capital del país este
jueves esto ocurre menos de dos semanas
después de que el tifón ondoy azotará al
país provocando más de 25 muertos maría
clara calle nos cuenta más sobre la
situación de la actual de la actual
tormenta tropical
filipinas no se termina de recuperar del
tifón más fuerte del mundo en 2020
cuando ya se prepara para banco en la
noche del miércoles las provincias del
sur del país fueron azotadas por esta
tormenta tropical banco golpeó manila o
con vientos de 320 kilómetros por hora
aunque ahora estos se redujeron a 125
kilómetros por hora los ojos están
puestos en que el tifón golpeará este
jueves a manila la capital mientras los
filipinos ven otra vez sus calles y sus
casas inundadas
es la segunda vez la primera fue durante
el tifa mando pero no esperaba que fuera
así mi esposo y yo estábamos acostados
cuando una conmoción con mis vecinos y
mi esposo salió él vio eso el agua ya
estaba tan alta así que salimos
corriendo y solo traje mi ripoll
ondeando al lado
aunque el tifón banco todavía no ha
llegado a manila la capital filipina ya
suspendió los vuelos y el transporte
público por las fuertes lluvias los
habitantes de las costas de la ciudad
también se preparan y ya comenzaron a
evacuar sus casas a ganarme en el piso a
nada más hemos aconsejado a nuestros
residentes que evacuen temprano ya que
nuestra idea está propensa a fuertes
vientos e inundaciones vaga máxicas la
tormenta banco ya deja por lo menos una
persona muerta en el sur del país pero
no se compara con el tifón goni que dejó
25 personas muertas seis desaparecidas y
miles de hogares destruidos en octubre
de este año
cambiamos de información el ejército de
etiopía aseguró que más de 550 soldados
rebeldes han muerto desde que el
gobierno central lanzó el pasado
miércoles una ofensiva militar contra el
frente de liberación de tigre en poder
de esa región del norte del país y
fronteriza con sudán y eritrea ante este
conflicto ya son al menos ocho mil
etíopes los que han cruzado hacia el
vecino país de sudan y se calcula que
asciendan a doscientos mil los que huyan
para buscar refugio por su parte el
presidente del consejo soberano sudanés
se reunió con los políticos etíopes para
fomentar las relaciones y cooperación en
esa frontera
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúe con
nosotros feliz día para todos
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de este año un millón más de
hogares nos ven